[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo debido a la situación de kobe
19 en esta ocasión trabajamos desde casa
el 4 de agosto el mundo vio como una
impresionante explosión sacudió la
capital de líbano decenas de
videoaficionados captaron el momento
exacto de aquel fatídico suceso y las
redes sociales hicieron lo suyo en
instantes el mundo sabía lo que ocurría
en beirut edificios destrozados y
vehículos volcados en las calles fue el
resultado de la peor explosión que ha
sacudido a este país de medio oriente
que dejó más de 170 personas muertas la
causa según las autoridades dos mil
setecientos cincuenta toneladas de
nitrato de amonio que habían sido
decomisadas a un buque de carga y
almacenadas en el hangar del puerto de
beirut en 2013 a juicio de los libaneses
fue un acto de negligencia por parte de
sus dirigentes a quienes achacan la
crisis económica que tiene a cerca del
45 por ciento de la población por debajo
del umbral de la pobreza indignados por
la explosión se echaron de nuevo las
calles y precipitaron por segunda vez la
caída del gobierno
últimos diez meses
los libaneses no lo aguantaban más desde
octubre de 2019 ya habían estallado en
un movimiento llamado la revolución del
whatsapp una ola de manifestaciones
contra el gobierno que en su intento por
aumentar los ingresos del país propuso
cobrar impuestos por las llamadas
realizadas a través de aplicaciones
móviles de acuerdo con los mismos
ciudadanos las redes sociales fueron
clave en la organización de las
protestas entrevistamos a alexandra el
sáhara y giba tandil y sus activistas
libanesas que coincidieron en la
efectividad de estas plataformas
digitales a la hora de organizar estas
protestas
durante todo este tiempo las únicas
buenas movilizaciones que se han dado
han sido a través de las redes sociales
en instagram en twitter en grupos de
whatsapp
& world fue en redes sociales e
instagram donde se estaban esparciendo
las noticias más rápido que incluso en
los canales de televisión de empeños
faster y band and action mí ya no no
sabes a veces me pregunto cómo la gente
se revolucionaba antes de las redes
sociales porque éstas juegan un papel
gigante en esto
el poder de los medios sigue allí pero
el poder de las redes sociales facebook
instagram
facebook instagram e incluso twitter hoy
es un elemento importante en el
esparcimiento de mensajes campañas de
discrimination of masters giles
campins
ampliando el círculo de nuestro alcance
aurich
pero así como se han organizado para
protestar también se han encargado de
consolidar todo movimiento para
reconstruir beirut y ayudar a sus
ciudadanos
instagram por ejemplo no sólo se ha
convertido en un punto de contacto local
sino también internacional toda una red
de personas dispuestas a ayudar con
donaciones y limpieza de la ciudad se
calcula que más de 250.000 personas se
quedaron sin hogar y en internet se
mueven distintas campañas para mitigar
la situación bajo el numeral ar holmes
ar open o nuestros hogares están
abiertos miles de usuarios han ofrecido
un lugar donde alojarse thawra map una
plataforma que es originalmente
utilizada para identificar lugares de
protesta de repente se convirtió en una
herramienta para facilitar la
localización de alojamiento gratuito o
camas disponibles la crisis económica y
los problemas del gobierno para
proporcionar servicios básicos también
afectan la conectividad a internet que
de por sí es una de las peores en todo
el mundo la escasez de energía y el
combustible necesario para producirla ha
generado problemas en la cobertura
iván nos habló de los desafíos que
genera esta situación
we did not gates any kind of government
of social software we did not siempre y
desde el primer día de la explosión
siempre fue la gente que trabajó junta
para levantar al país del desastre que
han hecho durante los últimos años es
the people the people that's what to be
there
incluyendo esos derechos básicos que al
día de hoy no tenemos
e incluyen incluso hoy en la capital hay
brechas en la cobertura que obstaculiza
que mucha información sea esparcida en
las redes sociales
esto se suma a la vigilancia que las
autoridades ejercen sobre el contenido
publicado en línea y por lo cual muchos
han sido llamados a interrogatorios
alexandra por ejemplo mencionó la
existencia de una especie de ejército
cibernético
ni siquiera se trata de tener un
ejército para el mismo gobierno no
funciona así en líbano
tenemos diferentes partidos y cada uno
de estos partidos tiene su propio
ejército y mis colegas en las redes
sociales la policía los llamó y les
preguntó por qué publicaste algo así
stamping guaita trataron de enjuiciarlos
por ello las redes sociales también han
sido el escenario donde circulan todo
tipo de teorías vinculadas con la
explosión y los medios de comunicación
han ido descartando las la nube en forma
de hongo que se produjo en el lugar de
la explosión llevó a algunos a pensar
que se trató de una bomba atómica aunque
explosiones distintas también producen
un hongo como ese el portal
estadounidense businessinsider consultó
a expertos en armas nucleares que
dijeron que el estallido carecía de dos
características distintivas de una
detonación nuclear un destello
enceguecedor y un aumento en la
temperatura que hubiera quemado todo
a su paso la bbc de londres recopiló
varias falsas teorías entre ellas una
que habla sobre un ataque planificado
por israel esta foto por ejemplo que
circula en internet muestra al primer
ministro benjamin netanyahu
supuestamente apuntando al sitio de la
explosión el portal recuerda que se
trató de una imagen de 2018 durante una
asamblea general de la onu en la que el
líder israelí apunto a un sitio distinto
de beirut donde afirmó que hezbollah
estaba escondiendo armas
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quiere repetir este u otro episodio
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
francia 24 punto com
[Música]